we miss you very much and we need to
know we want to ask how are you I'm okay
yeah Tamera Mowry Housley returned to
the real just over two weeks after her
niece college freshman Elena Housley was
killed at the borderline Bar and Grille
shooting in Thousand Oaks California
her family's been through a lot yeah but
the interesting thing about grief is
that you've got to find the balance of
moving forward in grieving at the same
time Tamera received a warm welcome back
from the audience as well as her
co-hosts Loni love Adrienne Houghton and
Jeannie Mai just appreciate the
outpouring of love and support from
everybody that sweet eighteen year old
girl impacted people in such a positive
way and that's how we've been able to
move on et's Kevin Frazier spoke to
Tamara's husband following the
heartbreaking news of his nieces death
no there's an impossible day we didn't
hurt anybody and was
program overseas and no since this man
thank you appreciate it appreciate she
volunteered to coach soccer she was just
a good human being you've been out here
all day long how hard has it been to see
these families in and to be in there and
and you were standing out in front of
the bar trying to call her correct yeah
what you do is just mine she's my
goddaughter you know
[Music]